Norse mythology tells the story of
jormungan a Great Serpent so long that
it wraps itself the entire way around
midgard and bites its own tail Legend
says that when yorman Gunther unclasps
its jaws and starts to unfurl it will
signal the beginning of Ragnarok the
destruction of the world and that was
about as much information as the
foundation gave to agent Nielsen when
they assigned him to his watch Duty in
Greenland in the frozen tundra all day
every day he had been equipped with a
sniper rifle thermal goggles and put up
high in a watchtower if he saw anyone
anyone he had to shoot on sight no
questions asked whether it was his Squad
mates the Brigadier general or even his
own mother if anyone walked across the
barren stretch of ice ahead of him he
was to shoot them dead under no
circumstances was anyone allowed to
enter that cave the fate of the world
could depend on it but it was cold and
the days were long for months he'd been
sitting there by himself without seeing
a single soul walk across the glacier
that's why it took him so long to spy
the figure stumbling across the ice half
a kilometer away but the person didn't
look any clearer when agent Nielsen took
a look through his thermal binoculars
barely registering as much warmer than
the snow around him the man stumbled
forward seemingly unaware of the world
around him could this be the start of
the Swan Song of the world is this what
he had been warned about without a
moment's hesitation agent Nielsen
snatched up the sniper rifle and readied
his sights on the man some were buried
deep beneath the Greenland ice is one of
the most dangerous scps that the
foundation has ever come across to say
that scp-722's Reawakening could spell
the destruction of human civilization is
no idle concern classified as a cutter
level SCP
scp-722 has been nicknamed jormungandra
after the Norse myth researchers
speculate that the creature's existence
could in some way linked to the early
origins of the story of the Norse
creature 722 was brought to the
foundation's attention relatively
recently environmental activist group
Greenpeace was shooting a documentary on
the effects of global warming on
glaciers in Greenland a small crew
including a director producer three
camera operators and a sound recordist
headed out to get some close-up footage
from amongst the glaciers walking from
ice sheet to ice sheet they noticed
several rounded entrances to what looked
like deep Ice Caves surmising that these
openings were only accessible to them
because of the melting Glacier Ice the
crew climbed down into the cave to get
some never-before-seen footage some of
the footage of their exploration has
been recovered since and in the
background of several shots as they are
adjusting exposure and pulling Focus you
can hear the producer and director
theorizing about where these caves have
come from they initially seem to think
that the caves are Millennia old
preserved by Sub-Zero temperatures but
soon they come across several markings
on the walls ancient hieroglyphs and
symbols none of the crew were language
experts and so in the footage you can
hear them struggling to identify which
people group would have carved those
into the ice walls in the decades since
language experts from around the world
have studied these markings on those
walls and have still been unable to
identify any discernible links to any
known human script most agree that it
does seem to predate the settlement of
the island by Eric the Red at the start
of the 11th century during this period
it is believed that there were no human
settlements on the island so the origins
of this script remain unknown as the
footage goes on you may start to notice
something that the Greenpeace crew does
not one of the ice walls is no longer a
wall at all it looks like a rock in some
of the footage but whenever a flashlight
Shines on its surface you can see a
pattern to it scales then an opening at
the far side of the tunnel the crew
emerges into an enormous Cavern
estimated to be upwards of 200 meters in
height and several times wider even
their powerful flashlights struggle to
cut through the darkness inside that's
the point that the sound recordist
notices the scales running alongside
them as the camera pans you see that
they have been walking alongside a tail
several times taller than them a tail
that snakes its way through the darkness
of the cavern to meet a hulking mass at
the other side shrouded in darkness that
is where the footage cuts off those
Greenpeace filmmakers were next seen in
a local town that evening none of them
had the chance to extol the wonders of
what they'd encountered that day as they
were all sick a couple went straight to
bed in their lodgings complaining of
intense headaches and exhaustion others
tried to check themselves into the ER
but never made it each of the crew died
of different causes necrosis of the skin
internal bleeding kidney failure by 9 pm
that day all of them were dead
fortunately there just so happened to be
a low-level Foundation agent staying in
the same guest house says them who heard
the commotion within two days a
perimeter was established within two
years the foundation gained the bulk of
knowledge of this SCP that they rely on
to this day it is unknown exactly how
large scp-722 actually is a hulking
serpent half buried in ice much of its
body cannot be observed its sleeps
coiled up in the middle of the cavern
that the filmmakers happened across some
of its bodies buried beneath fallen in
parts of the caves others frozen into
the ground around it however based on
what can be observed of this SCP it is
estimated to be in the ranges of 8 to 12
kilometers from head to tail fortunately
for just about everyone including you
this SCP appears to be dormant at no
time since its Discovery has this SCP
been observed to move make a sound or
otherwise indicate Consciousness sensors
are installed in the chamber to monitor
its life functions and study its heart
rate temperature brain activity and more
one concern to the foundation is that
since its Discovery 722 has had a 0.9
uptick in neural activity researchers
hope that this is just a natural part of
this sleep cycle and that it will return
to a deeper Slumber soon that is the
hope at least so what makes this SCP so
dangerous then if it's sound to sleep
well let's go back to agent Nielsen
steering through the scope of his rifle
the barrel kicked back a puff of warm
smoke there and gone in cold air he
watched just long enough to confirm the
kill before radioing back to command
what he had observed within an hour the
cleanup crew arrived riding on
snowmobiles they waited at a distance
for an hour before approaching the body
rather unceremoniously they wrapped it
up in a black plastic bag strapped it to
the back of their snowmobile and took it
away for cremation Nielsen just sat
there in his Watchtower the whole time
observing it all the person looked sick
and not the kind of sick that you'd get
from spending too much time out there on
the ice there skin had gone rotten like
they had gangrene or leprosy it wasn't
just your usual frostbite most
concerning they'd been wearing a
jumpsuit standard issue for d-class
personnel only a vial held in their cold
dead fingers was any kind of clue for
Nielsen as to what had been going on in
that cave but that was as close as the
agent ever came to understanding the
mysteries of scp-722 the vial however
was in many ways all he needed to know
that is because contained in that vial
was a sample of the liquid secreted by
722 it is a liquid that the Greenpeace
crew came into close contact with when
they found the creature and it's a
liquid that promises and denies great
power and great risk to the foundation
any and all attempts to study this
liquid in any meaningful sense have
failed anyone who comes into contact
with it will immediately suffer acute
sickness interestingly however there
seems to be little consistency as to how
this sickness manifests itself some
develop a number of cancerous cells
whilst others lose cognitive function
due to brain swelling symptoms seem to
vary from person to person naturally
this makes studying the substance very
difficult hazardous material suits have
been deployed for researchers attempting
to study it but have all failed despite
being otherwise effective against
chemical biological and radioactive
threats how the substance is able to
infect them is unknown sadly a good
number of scientists had to die to make
this discovery another route of study is
to take the substance out of the cave
and observe it under laboratory
conditions this was what agent Nielsen
observed as he shot and killed the
d-class Personnel emerging from the Cave
the d-class had been sent in to retrieve
the vial of the substance for external
study while a safe and direct route of
entry and exit had been planned for the
man to take he became critically ill
whilst in contact with 722 and developed
an aggressive fever no longer coherent
over the radio he dropped out of signal
wandering through the tunnels for two
hours until emerging out of an exit high
up on the glacier two agents with higher
security clearance were dispatched to
deal with the body the reason for their
weight was for their own safety 722's
toxin appears to denature with time away
from its source causing it to weaken in
potency if they had approached
immediately they may have well suffered
similar Fates to the d-class they
survived but the sample was ruined all
subsequent attempts have also been met
with failure it seems almost impossible
to capture a clean sample and transport
it any kind of distance with this toxin
the foundation would have possession of
an immense biological weapon akin to the
discovery of the atom bomb but as of
right now all it's good for is killing
d-class Personnel initially the
foundation believed the fluid to be a
defense mechanism for the SCP something
to protect it in its deep sleep but the
more time is spent observing it the more
time claim this perception is Shifting
scp-722's toxin appears instead to be a
weapon as such the containment of this
creature is of Paramount importance
there are eight known access points into
the tunnel Network that would Grant
access to scp-722 each of them has been
sealed with reinforced gates with
additional layers of soundproofing at
regular 4-Hour intervals nitrogen gas
cooled to a near liquid state is to be
pumped through these doors without fail
it is believed that the creature is a
form of proto-reptile and so is
theoretically cold-blooded its internal
temperature is dictated by its
surroundings therefore by keeping a cool
average temperature in these caves it is
thought that this SCP Slumber can be
prolonged how long is unclear with
Rising global temperatures year after
year the threat that the Greenpeace
activists worth proclaiming is very real
just perhaps not quite in the way they'd
envisioned Not only would there be an
increase in natural disaster features
and a decrease in biodiversity there
would also be a 12 kilometer snake
roaming around the planet killing anyone
in its path not ideal as such the
foundation has also planted a number of
Highly skilled individuals in prominent
environmental positions in the hopes of
turning the tide of global warming
sooner should the ice in that cave
system warm by even a couple of degrees
who knows what kind of Spike they might
see on the neural monitors this SCP
naturally is buried deep beneath layers
and layers of security clearances too
only in exceptional circumstances and
for Vital maintenance is anyone allowed
to approach this SCP a minimum of two
level three clearance agents are
required to sign off on any such Works
in recent years a new Brigadier General
took charge of the containment
operations of scp-722 after his
predecessor was stripped of his duties
overly zealous experiments and
increasingly desperate attempts to
harvest or synthesize the 722 toxin saw
an alarming uptick in neural activity
over 40 d-class Personnel were processed
and disposed of within a two-week period
in an attempt to assemble a micro
laboratory within the main chamber
itself this project failed and the
noises of construction threatened the
piece that had so long been maintained
beneath the glacier the new Brigadier
General is taking no such risks
enforcing a zero tolerance policy on
anyone approaching site 103 unless
suitably cleared a number of hikers have
sadly had to be killed this way but the
foundation believes it to be a necessary
sacrifice to keep the peace it is quite
easy to find a convincing backstory for
their untimely deaths and the lack of
bodies to bury just another person to
get lost and fall down a crack in the
glacier warning stories that are shared
and planted in local towns and on the
internet the only threat to this current
piece is a new Avenue of inquiry that
researchers have stumbled across a link
to a group of animals found halfway
around the world monitor lizards of the
genus varanas seem to share a similar
set of traits to scp-722 namely the
nature of their toxins you may be
familiar with the bite of a Komodo
dragon while the initial wound sure does
hurt the real damage comes in the
following hours and days as necrosis
sets in from the toxins in its mouth
could these creatures share a common
ancestor could 722 be the common
ancestor as of right now it is just a
hunch but it's one that has taken root
amongst the research staff in order to
find out more though they need samples
tissue samples taken straight from the
SCP itself the only way to do back is to
go back into the caves and start cutting
if a bit of construction noise was
enough to raise brain activity by 0.9
percent taking a hunk of Flesh could
prove a whole lot more dangerous not
least for the Personnel involved who
will all have to sacrifice their lives
the potential benefits could be huge a
way to study fatal diseases in a new
light perhaps finding a way to reverse
engineer cures to some of the deadliest
conditions on the planet or perhaps the
missing ingredient to synthesizing the
most powerful biological weapon in human
history maybe worst of all it could all
trigger The Reawakening do you remember
how the story of yormangan dorenz with a
prediction that when the Great
Serpentine coils the end of the world
Ragnarok itself will arrive but that's
just an old fairy tale right now go
check out scp-3000 and atashisha and
what is the biggest SCP